when you think of australia you might
think of kangaroos koalas or premium
australian beer
like foster's lager sorry aussies but
another thing you might think of
is the distinct australian way or ways
of speaking english
the story of australian english begins
with the arrival of european settlers in
australia in 1788.
convicts from britain and ireland were
exiled to new south wales which was
founded as an
overseas penal colony they weren't all
ruthless criminals mind you
many of them were only guilty of theft
and some of them were children
over 160 000 convicts were sent there
over the next 80 years
mainly working-class people from the
major cities of england as well as
scotland wales and ireland
there were also many free settlers who
joined them the significance of this is
that people speaking different english
dialects from all over britain and
ireland were essentially thrown together
in the same place
where they had to learn to understand
one another remember back then there was
no radio or television to familiarize
people with different accents
in order to understand each other well
they had to learn to speak in a way that
was
less regional this resulted in dialect
leveling
dialectal variations were removed from
their speech
you could say that the core of
australian english is a compromise
between the various regional dialects of
britain and ireland
and since then australian english has
developed its own features words and
expressions
it has also been influenced by
additional waves of immigration since
the days of the penal colony ended
there are basically three varieties of
australian english
broad general and cultivated australian
english
they essentially form an accent
continuum with the speaker's accent
depending mostly on whether they grew up
in a rural area or an urban area
their socioeconomic background and
perhaps the kind of subculture they
identify with
broad australian english has the
features that people outside of
australia tend to associate with
australian english
you know when they think of steve irwin
the crocodile hunter or maybe paul hogan
and crocodile dundee
and just a word of warning australians
never say this
throw another shrimp on the barbie
unless they're taking the piss
out of you taking the piss is an
expression used in britain and australia
that means to make fun of someone or
mess with them
it's not used in north american english
i'm canadian and i sometimes use it but
that's because i've picked it up from
some aussie friends of mine
here are a few examples of broad
australian english that you'll probably
only hear in rural areas or maybe
amongst older people
or amongst um is it politically correct
to say
awkers and bogans yeah
does that mean no no yeah
women are sometimes referred to as
sheilas somehow that one particular name
sheila came to represent women in
general for example if i say
hey man where's liam in theory i might
get this reply
now he's over there having a chat with
some sheila struth
she's a bit of a looker struth is used
as an interjection to show surprise
it actually originated in the uk and is
a contraction of
god's truth but now it's used much more
in australia
it's truth well at least in broad
australian english
a similar word is karaki this is also
used as an interjection to show surprise
but again this is limited to broad
australian english
unless someone's taken the piss taking
the piss cultivated australian english
is spoken by less than 10 percent of
aussies
non-aussies might mistake it for british
received pronunciation
it has many fewer obviously australian
features
general australian english is spoken by
the majority of aussies and is somewhere
between the two
these different varieties of australian
english are not regional
for the most part it's hard to tell the
difference between people from brisbane
melbourne sydney and other cities based
on their accents
some people also argue that there's a
fourth accent the accent of the outer
suburbs of major cities which developed
among communities that have immigrated
to australia since the second world war
this kind of accent is often perceived
as an immigrant accent
though it's spoken among the children
and grandchildren of immigrants
and crosses ethnic boundaries in those
neighborhoods
most of the examples after this point in
the video will be more or less
general australian english spelling
australian english normally follows
british spelling conventions
rather than american that means in words
like organize and authorize
the isc spelling is normally preferred
to the iz-e spelling
words like color and flavor are spelled
with our
rather than or words like center and
liter are spelled with re
rather than er and so on the reason why
american english uses different
spellings from british english is
because of noah webster
whose dictionary published in 1828 chose
certain variant spellings to be the
american ones
in order to make american english
distinct this was specific to the u.s so
it didn't affect australia
pronunciation australian accents are
arless accents or
non-rhotic accents meaning that the r
sound is not pronounced at the end of a
syllable or word
unless there's a word beginning with a
vowel after it this is the same as in
most accents of england
for example k compare that to my rhodic
canadian accent
care okay i don't care i don't care
different accents of english are mainly
distinguished by differences in vowels
and that's the case with australian
english for instance aussie english
basically has two a sounds
some words are pronounced with a in both
australian and north american english
for example cat cat nap nap
but other words that i would pronounce
with an a sound are often pronounced
differently
with a long ah in australian english for
example
bath bath laugh laugh
this is because of a split that occurred
in the early modern english vowel
ah in southern england the sound began
to change to a long ah sound as in
father before certain cells
this is referred to as broad a this
change made its way to australia
but the vowel became a central vowel
rather than a back vowel
ah rather than the british word boss
this distinction is not used across the
board in australian english though
it has the most influence in south
australia
the most noticeable feature of
australian english pronunciation is
probably its diphthongs
an australian greeting i'm sure you've
heard is g'day
or g'day mate it's really only aussies
who use this as a greeting
but if i tried to say it it would sound
like good day mate
listen to the difference in the
diphthongs the vowel sounds good day
mate right the word day is not to be
confused with the word
die die the equivalent of american and
british
i is i for example price
price hide hide there's also a different
australian pronunciation of the diff
long that i would pronounce as
ow australians say something like
hell downtown downtown
there's also a diphthong that i
pronounce as oi
australians say something more like oi
boy the aussie sound is less open
another is the diphthong o as in boat
australians say
there are some characteristic features
of intonation in australian english
one such feature is called high rising
terminal this means that australians
often say clauses within a statement
with intonation that rises at the end
like a yes or no question in north
american or british english
in the following example you can hear it
at the end of the first clause
uh met robbo down the park
then we met up with a couple of mates
and played a bit of footy
this kind of intonation is standard in
australia these days you might hear it
sometimes in north america and the uk as
well
though a lot of people find it annoying
you might hear it referred to as
uptalk vocabulary while the vast vast
majority of australian english
vocabulary is the same as in other
varieties
it does have its own word preferences as
well as words and expressions that are
uniquely aussie
the most famous aussie phrase just might
be get i might
as we heard before just like in the uk
aussies often refer to friends as mates
as in the uk the word mate is used in
contexts where north americans would say
friend or maybe
man when addressing someone casually but
unlike in the uk
in australia mate is not limited to
casual situations or to your peers
you can use it with older people or
people with a higher rank or position
than you
this reflects the overwhelmingly casual
nature of aussies and the way they
communicate
to inquire about someone's well-being
you might hear them ask
there you go as a north american this
sounds strange to my years
we ask how's it going rather than how
are you going
similarly when you apologize an aussie
might say you're right
rather than that's all right which is
what i would say the first time i heard
this i was confused like why are you
telling me i'm all right
another expression that's likely to
confuse us north americans is
she'll be right mate who's she referring
to well
no one it's referring to the situation i
would say
it'll be all right or it'll be fine
when aussies want to get someone's
attention you might hear them say
i would say hey instead well you might
hey man
fair income or just dinkum this
expression means genuine honest or true
it can also be used as a question fair
income for real
and it can be used as an adjective to
describe someone he's a fading
aussie this is like saying he's a true
aussie
i've come across a couple of possible
etymologies of this expression
one of them states that it comes from a
dialectal word of england
dinkum meaning hard work another
etymology
states that it comes from cantonese
which was spoken by prospectors in the
early gold mines
dingum meaning real gold though i tend
to think the first etymology is the
correct one
remember that sentence from a moment ago
he's a fading aussie
well we could expand that a little he's
a fair income true blue aussie
mate i might say he's a real genuine
aussie
true blue this phrase is kind of like
fair dinkum meaning true
as in genuine but also has the meaning
of loyal
and all the people with that positive
personality trait i say
good on you good on you is what aussies
say when they want to show they're
impressed or they respect something good
you've done
i would probably say nice work or good
job from what i understand
good anya comes from hiberno english
that is
irish english note that good anya can be
used both sincerely and sarcastically
for example let's say i'm bragging about
how much of a pimp i am and how i scored
last night
yeah right i might good on ya when you
say thanks and aussie might reply with
no worries which is like saying no
problem or don't worry about it
no worries can also be used in response
to an apology
no worries is a way of life in australia
and something of a national motto
aussies tend to be light-hearted and not
take things too seriously but if you're
one of those people who tends to
complain or sulk
or if you're easily offended you might
be called a suk or as an adjective
aussies love to use diminutive words
special forms of words that show
endearment
this is usually done through shortening
a word and adding a special suffix to it
afternoon becomes this afternoon becomes
this arbo or server barbecue becomes
bobby mosquito becomes muzzy football
becomes
footy cigarette becomes siggy sandwich
becomes
sanger postman becomes posty garbage man
becomes
gaba christmas becomes chrissy
chocolate biscuit chocky bicky surface
station becomes
servo and that's for a service station
meaning a gas station or petrol station
mcdonald's becomes maccas and this is
ubiquitous throughout australia
isolation becomes oh so as in
quarantine due to 19. how'd you go
during iso
there were also some words in aussie
english that originate in aboriginal
languages of australia
one example you might hear in particular
in broad australian english
is which means hard work yaka
is a word from the yagara language which
used to be spoken in the brisbane region
this word made its way into australian
english through the english-based pidgin
language that was originally used
between european settlers and
aboriginals
that pigeon later developed into
australian creole which is still spoken
by around 20 000 people today in the
northern territory
there are some other well-known nouns
that represent specific things in the
australian environment
like dingo or boomerang which come from
the extinct
darug language which used to be spoken
in the sydney area
australian english is largely the same
as other varieties of english but with
their own accents vocabulary and
attitude that reflect the laid-back
nature of aussies
endearing and friendly are two words
that come to mind when i think of
aussies and their way of speaking
english
oh one final feature of australian
english that we can get into
is their extremely liberal use of the
word
though youtube might ban me if i talk
about that so
maybe i should just move on to the
question of the day
for speakers of aussie english i'm sure
there are heaps of aussie words and
expressions that i didn't have time to
mention in the video
so what other ones would you like to add
write them in the comments down below
and this is the part of the video when i
say thanks to my patreon patrons
especially my top tier patrons whose
names appear on the screen
becoming a member on patreon gives you
various benefits like early releases
ad free and promotion free videos and
access to a patrons only online
community
check out patreon.com langfocus for more
information
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you